rob is with us in Pennsylvania hey Rob
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thank you very much for taking my call
my honor sir how can I help
um I just finished a Total Money
Makeover and I'm starting I'm about to
start baby step two
I am one of those people that is
crippled by student loan debt I'm
currently sitting around 118 thousand
dollars in debt on student loans I went
to one of those fancy private colleges I
have about twelve thousand dollars on a
car loan or sure degree hundred dollars
it was gonna be history education gonna
be you didn't graduate well I did but
when my last semester came to student
teach the student loan department said
that they weren't sure that I was gonna
be able to pay back the money with the
degree that I earned so they kind of
dropped me so I ended up you know going
through finding work so you never got
$40.00 ikut I never did but I did go
back and I finished my history degree I
paid cash for the last class I needed
and I ended up finding myself into
manufacturing management afterwards so
you have it so here a degree
undergraduate for 118,000 yes okay and
what do you make now our household
income right now is about 73 okay and
you're working 40 hours is your wife she
is working close to 40 she has two
part-time jobs that she's working right
now one and that's usually in the
morning one in the evening or - I'm
working 40 she's an HR team member for a
retail store okay so she's not got a
great job uh it's you know you're just
just it's not a full-time job number one
number two it doesn't pay much right
right that's what I'm I'm I'm the
majority household income if not all of
it and I just picked up a second
part-time job for about twenty five
hours a week to try and chip away at
some of this good what are you making it
um it's just that it's just at a retail
store for
ten dollars now eleven dollars an hour
but you probably do that or $500 a month
you can probably do better than that
tutoring kids on history probably make
$25 no greater than that
besides that you have a history besides
that you have a desire to teach yeah I
did I actually really wanted to and then
life just didn't work out that way I
mean you could you can do this as your
sad hustle we can set you up as a tutor
go visit some local schools and teach
history find out what the curriculum is
that needs to be taught so they can get
their classes passed and okay you can
make 25 bucks an hour doing that man get
in high school students through history
okay promise you can and so anyway let's
work on that and do better than $10 just
ed of settling and it sounds like you're
just now kind of getting around on top
of this and so he what is your payment
on the 118 the one I would to love them
are federal loans and one of them is a
private loan that I consolidated with
because I was getting ripped off by
Sallie Mae at 13% who so I transferred
it to a sofa loan that five and a half
so I got a much better rate on that so I
tried to save some money on that good so
what are your payments on the student
loans what's the total they total about
a thousand dollars a month little over
okay and what's your house payment about
nine hundred almost okay good and you
got a car payment and that's it right
now yeah long you've been married
it's 300 but we just hit six years okay
all right so what we're going to do is
roll up your sleeves and we're going to
increase your side hustle and work on
your wife's career increase her income
so that you're going to approach a
hundred thousand up from seventy and
we're gonna be on a really tight budget
a detailed written gameplan on every
dollar because we're looking for a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars over
the next three years four years forty
thousand a year for three years gets you
out okay
and if I said a plan for five years at
most dad I was also thinking to my
question my main question was I have
about nine hundred days of deferment
time
all my federal loans we've done know
he's wondering if I should there's no
point in doing it we're trying to get
rid of it you'd only know it only
deferred if you can't pay it deferment
gives you no benefit whatsoever it just
puts it off it kicks the can down the
road okay I didn't know if it could be
the the money that I could use to start
my death snowball to pay off the car the
credit card and then start really should
be able to find that anyway because
we're increasing your income and
tightening your expenses there's more
room in this Internet so you've got the
car and 100 at the car at 12 118 it is
130 right mm-hmm
makes you debt-free okay so $45,000
times 3 years and you're out of debt but
that's a lot more than you're paying now
but we've increasing her income or
increasing your income and we're putting
you on the tightest of tightest of tight
budgets and and it's not going to all
happen at once but if you can average
that you can if you can average
forty-five thousand you can be out in
three years and if you don't average
that you'll be out in four years five
years is too long on this and say all
I'm doing is dividing 130 by three it's
all I did okay and I'm saying 45,000 out
of a hundred means you're living on
nothing but we got to get your income up
and your outgo down and really lean into
this and you can turn this around I in
the other thing is I think what's going
to happen is both of your careers are
going to mature during this 2 or 2/3 or
period of time and by mature I mean
they're gonna move more into the zone or
where they're supposed to be and your
incomes are gonna come up because now
you're really focusing on it because now
you have to and so very cool hey thank
you for the call I appreciate you
joining us so the moral of the story is
don't spend a hundred and eighteen
thousand dollars to get a history degree
from a private university peer
unless you pay cash if you pay cash you
can afford to have this luxury but
you're not going to get a return on
investment on that and I'm not mad at
people with history degrees but there's
really basically one place to make a
living with a history degree and that's
a teaching certificate teaching in the
high school unless you go on and get
your masters or your PhD and you teach
at the collegiate level at the
university level otherwise your history
degree doesn't have application in the
marketplace and you end up working for a
manufacturing organization which is what
he's doing it's not a bad guy this is
what's happened to everybody in America
so we have to stop and we have to think
folks it's exactly what this borrowed
future podcast is about while I'm
pushing this so hard